how are you good to see you know what I  was thinking we're really close I was  thinking about you earlier because ya  know I think we should just do the  interview like this well congrats on con  man season two I was on set for I  believe it was the last episode I know a  lot goes down what can you tell us about  what's coming up I think we get a little  more of a dose of reality we know  Rainier Lee's reality in season one I  think this year this season with it we  get to know a little bit more of also  Jack Moors we always do this anymore I'm  not doing it I'm done how is Alan Tudyk  doing on set it's like gone to his head  now that he's in a store like he forgets  he gets these amazing rules that be the  first thing I did I got a role in Star  Wars he's rubbing it and all my friends  face hey it's just an island style for  my star  [Music]